I do miss certain things my restaurant
my cigar bar my this my that but I am so
happy that I made the move because what
you get out of going to a red state is
not only you get to save a lot of money
on taxes not only do you get more normal
people generally around you not only do
you frequently get a your dollar going a
lot further than they do in some of
these blue metropolises but you get the
standard back to a sane place any place
you move to you move to Tennessee
There's plenty of Libs in Tennessee but
the the center of gravity there the
political center of gravity is not as
nearly as far over to the left if you're
living in a place like California the
the dividing line between right and left
is do you trans the kids at four or do
you wait to trans the kids at seven you
know I mean that's that's how far left
it is I say this with almost no
exaggeration whereas in Tennessee even
the Democrats are still relatively
normal